if overlord makes less in this movie I'm
gonna be really pissed I'm gonna
probably will which is pretty much me
guaranteeing that I'm gonna be pissed
after the weekend the girl in this
spider's web and first of all this is
not me saying this is a spoiler warning
I'm saying right here I will talk about
what the trailer showed you and what the
trailer showed me which I feel like
showed way too much there's in the
trailer so I'm gonna talk about it here
because I feel like if you're interested
in seeing this movie you saw the trailer
and if you saw the trailer you might not
be interested in seeing this movie and
if you didn't see the trailer you
probably have no interest in say in this
movie so I feel like it's probably fine
so the girl in the spider's web is the
sequel to The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo instead of Rooney Mara playing
Lisbeth Salander we have Claire Foy
let's do a fine job in both respective
movies fact Claire affording this movies
one of the things I like about the movie
and the plot of this movie essentially
it's a hacker thriller there's this
program that this guy made that will
give whoever has it way too much power
they will have essentially the nuclear
codes for the world with these codes
they will be able to unleash the first
episode of American Horror Story
Apocalypse that's the hacker chase is on
and no I did not describe the plot of a
90s movie well I did kind of it sounds
like it but that is the plot of this
movie something about it actually got to
reminded me of Goldeneye this thing that
will give whoever has it way too much
power the bad guys want it the good guys
need to get it before the bad guys do
villain in this movie is a specter of
the heroes past and just like the
trailer in Goldeneye this trailer ruins
that double-oh-seven is facing the
ultimate enemy
the man who knows him best hello James
what an unpleasant surprise double O six
someone always has to carry the pain now
it's your turn
sister [ __ ] trailers man granted for
the girl in the spider's web even if
that wasn't in the trailer you would
totally know movie sets it up at the
beginning it doesn't even hide it so
when the reveal happens you're like yeah
no [ __ ] as for what I liked in this
movie I liked clarify she was cool
efficient smart cunning badass I do get
a different vibe from her portrayal than
Rooney Mara I'm not saying it's good or
bad I just say I get a different vibe
you know kind of like the Dumbledore and
some of the action sequences were
actually really cool one of them up it's
shown in the dress where she's riding
the motorcycle across the ice I was
burning this movie has intrigue and it's
just that the intrigue is bogged down
with a lot of extra [ __ ] those movies
kind of a mess kind of a wreck the movie
just feels cluttered cramped convoluted
others in this movie having way too many
cogs to keep the wheel turning the
people are kind of idiots
other than her like she's the smartest
person in this movie by a clear mind bad
guys getting stabbed in a fight leaving
the bloody knife there at the crime
scene so people can just take DNA from
it and the people who never take DNA
from it or how about the fact this dude
is in a safehouse they cannot have the
bad guys find this guy the bad guys are
trying to kill this dude and directly
across the street you can see from the
bedroom window this big abandoned
building what you see her just sniper
positions up and down that thing like
mad people you just take you out cuz
you're right there worst safe house ever
but I'm gonna go ahead and chalk the bad
guys up to being idiots for the fact
that they never used the building to
snipe the dude I don't mean to be so
nitpicky but one nitpick leads to
another and now I'm just gonna dump it
on you but it's ridiculous like there's
the same with this dude there's his word
he doesn't know what it is he kind of
hits the stone walls I how is he ever
gonna figure it out and someone's like
oh that's a Russian word it means this
he's like it's Russian what you didn't
Google it you didn't think to google it
at all when I see a weird word I don't
know do you know what I do I google it
and I have yet to not get an answer from
that and well this movie does have some
intriguing action there was one action
sequence in particular it's really dark
really misty really foggy and everyone
including our hero is wearing a mask so
they all looked the same and I just
didn't know who was who in that fight I
was like is she winning are they winning
I don't know but there's this one part
where she's guiding this dude out of
this building she can't see the dude but
then he hesitates doesn't want to do a
thing then he agrees to do the thing so
she lets him out and he gets out just in
time to take care of this one dude but
if he didn't hesitate
it wouldn't work so did she know he
would have hesitated what did she plan
it as she got I don't know the movie
never tells me if she is or is not God
I'm kind of leaning that direction
that's pretty [ __ ] clairvoyance or
clairvoyant I my ability that God is
such a dad joke it's happening folks
soon I'm gonna start recording
vertically on my phone
dark times are ahead of us guys in the
end this movie was pretty well
represented by his trailer while
watching the trailer at first I was like
yeah I'm into this the trailer was
really messy and by the end I was like
man then while watching the movie I
first was like yeah I'm into this and
the movie was really messin by the
Andals like man fact is it's a hacker
thriller that feels like we have seen it
a hundred times before between 1993 and
now there have been a lot of those and
this one just offers nothing new really
I'm gonna say I'm not gonna remember
there's an t minus one day
yep already forgot funny enough there's
a scene at the end of the movie that is
straight-up ripped off from daredevil no
not the Netflix daredevil the Ben
Affleck daredevil when I saw the setup I
saw the scene I was like you're not
gonna daredevil us are you're not gonna
actually do the daredevil and daredevil
I don't know maybe that's how it was in
the book or the original movie I haven't
seen the original movie I haven't read
the book sure has been used in 147 other
movies but I thought it daredevil
where's the girl in the spider's web
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]